Every company takes security very seriously...
...so that company PCs may not have floppy disk drives nor any CD or DVD writable drives.
No one believes that their corporate computers don't have such devices...
...because their company cannot afford them.
The reality is that your company is deathly afraid of confidential corporate secrets leaking out.
Moreover, some corporate notebooks won't work...
...once they are away from the vicinity of the corporate wireless server...
...and it makes it more difficult for industrial spies to steal valuable data.
Even high storage USBs,...
...may perform only half of their normal function in some corporate computers:
...employees can read information stored in them...
...but cannot download information from their PCs to USB.
Some corporate e-mail systems are set up so that e-mails can be exchanged only among corporate PCs.
In addition, corporate documents are automatically encoded,....
...so outsiders cannot read them.
They're stored only on corporate servers along with the names of employees who have accessed them.
Then, if important documents are leaked,...
...your company can find the guilty party.
Yet, all this need for security hinders mobility and productivity.
More insidiously, employees are reminded of just how little trust their company has in them.
It's difficult to know which hurts morale more,...
...the one bad apple that steals or leaks corporate secrets or Big Brother...
...that watches and seeks to control its employees' every use of the tools of business.